What does living by the spirit look
like? And what about the former and
latter rain? That may take a long time
to explain that, but let's get to the
first part.
Let me pray. Father in heaven, as we
move into this question, continue to
instruct my mind and my mouth. In Jesus'
name I pray. Amen. The Bible says,
"There's therefore now no condemnation
to them which are in Christ Jesus, who
walk not after the flesh, but after the
spirit." Now,
condemnation is the opposite of
justification.
A justified person walks in the spirit,
which means according to the directions
of the spirit. And the directions of the
spirit are simply, "Thus saith the
Lord." That's why the spirit inspired
the psalmist to write, "Thy word is a
lamp unto my feet and a light unto my
path." Walking in the spirit is not some
esoteric spiritistic sort of experience
where you're floating on high. It is a
practical way to live. You live by "Thus
saith the Lord." When Jesus told Satan
in Matthew chapter 4 verse 4, "Man shall
not live by bread alone, but by every
word that proceedeth out of the mouth of
God," he practically said, "Man shall
live by the directions of the spirit,"
which are found in the Bible. And so we
live by every word. Psalm 119 verse 130,
"The entrance of thy word giveth light.
It giveth understanding." The word of
God is the way we are to live because
the word of God is the same means by
which the entire universe was made. By
the word of the Lord were the heavens
made. Hebrews 11:3, "Through faith we
understand that the worlds were formed
by the word of God." The entire creation
was done by the word of God. Bible
Commentary volume 1 page 1081, I believe
it's paragraph 1, Ellen White writes,
"God spoke and his word created his
works in the natural world. Everything
we see was by the word. Then we live by
that which brought the universe into
existence. What creates is what
sustains. That's a fundamental Bible
principle. 2 Peter 3:5,
"For this they willingly are ignorant
of, that by the word of God the heavens
were of old, and the earth standing out
of the water and in the water." That's
verse 5. Verse 7 said, "But the heaven
and the earth which are now by that same
word are kept in store." Hebrews 1:3,
"Upholding all things by the word of his
power." So the word that creates is the
word that sustains. That is how we live.
I'm going to say all of this to say to
walk in the spirit is to walk in the
commandments of God. Thus saith the
Lord. Ecclesiastes 12:13, "This is the
whole duty of man." What is the duty of
man? Fear God and keep his commandments.
This is walking in the spirit because
the Bible says the law is spiritual. It
was the Holy Spirit that wrote the law.
The Father wanted them spoken, Jesus
spoke them, the spirit wrote them as the
finger of God. And I don't have time to
get into that. When we obey God's
commandments, we are walking in the
spirit. God has no other standard than
the life of Christ as expressed in the
law, or the law as lived out in the life
of Christ. It's both the same thing. Let
me say again, to walk in the spirit is
to walk in obedience to God. And what
does God want me to obey? The 10
Commandments. They are the whole duty of
man. There's nothing strange about
walking in the spirit as a lot of
churches they use that expression so
loosely. He's in the spirit. He's
anointed. He's this. No, no, no, no.
What we're talking about is obedience by
the indwelling power of Christ. Someone
obeying God
is walking in the spirit.
Amen. So having the Holy working and
living by the Holy Spirit is not jumping
around and just Absolutely not.
What is jumping around is just your mind
because you're excited to be able to do
the work of God, right? And that that's
a great part. So the last question that
was the second part is, "What about the
former and latter rain?"
The former rain,
uh we saw it at Pentecost. It's based on
the agricultural cycle of ancient
Israel. You had the early rain to get
the harvest going. You had the latter
rain to
to ripen it and bring it to harvest. The
early rain, those two activities, which
were literal by the way, actual rain
came, they were symbolizing the
the the downpour of the spirit on
Pentecost in Acts chapter 2, and an
outpouring to come in these last days,
which will be much greater than what was
seen at Pentecost. And so the early rain
prepares us for the latter rain. Now,
there are some people who want to wait
straight for the latter rain without
having using without using the former
rain. It does not work. They go together
as verily as it worked in the
agricultural life where you literally
had early rain and then latter rain to
ripen the harvest, this is the way it
works in a Christian's life. The early
rain, in other words, what do you know
about God now? Do you know God wants you
to keep his commandments? Do you know he
wants you to keep the Sabbath? Do you
know he wants you to return a tithe? Do
you know he wants you to pray? Do you
know he wants you to break up that
adulterous relationship? Do you know he
wants you to stop cheating and stop
taking exams on Sabbath? Do you know
that? Do that.
That's the early rain. That prepares you
for the latter rain, which will come to
give power to the angel of Revelation
18:1-5, "Come out of her, my people."
But a disobedient person cannot with
power preach. "Come out of her, my
people," because that person is in the
same condition. The latter rain is given
to those who have used the former rain
or allowed the former rain to use them
if the rain represents the Holy Spirit.
In other words, Luke 16:10, "He that is
faithful in that which is least," that's
the that's the latter rain, "is faithful
also in much." That's the that Sorry.
"He that is faithful in that which is
least," that's the early rain, "is
faithful also in much." That's the
latter rain. Are you using the early
rain now? That small pouring as God
watches you and me and judges us. If
that person is faithful now, I can trust
that person to operate with the latter
rain, which is a tremendous outpouring
the world has never seen. But God will
never pour that out on someone who is
habitually disobedient and rebellious
against God despite going to church
every Sabbath or Sunday.
Amen to that. And that's why I believe
that as Jesus mentioned, uh we do not
have the Holy Spirit because we ask not,
right? And that that's something that we
have to do is daily praying for the Holy
Spirit. Daily prayer.
Um so we would take the whole day to
pray for the Holy Spirit, but we don't
do that, right? So thank you so much. Go
ahead. Asking for the spirit I'm glad
you raised that point.
We must ask. That's found in Matthew
7:11, Luke 11:13. "If ye then being
evil, know how to give good gifts unto
your children, how much more shall your
heavenly Father give the Holy Spirit to
them that ask him." Luke 11:13. But
there's something else beside ask.
In the book of Acts chapter 5 verse 32,
"God gives the Holy Spirit to them that
obey him."
Now, a lot of people just like ask. Let
me ask. Give me, give me, give me. They
don't like obeying him. In Hebrews 5:8,
"Christ is the author of eternal
salvation to all them that obey him."
The condition is obedience, but we hate
the word obedience. There's another
condition. Acts chapter 2 verse 38. On
the day of Pentecost, Peter was
preaching. He paused. The people said,
"What shall we do?" Peter said, "Repent
and be baptized every one of you for the
remission of sins, and ye shall receive
the gift of the Holy Ghost." So we have
at least three conditions. We have ask,
yes, ask. We have obey. We have, if
necessary, get baptized. There may be
other conditions. As you study the word
of God, the Holy Spirit comes close. And
so it's not just ask alone. That's No,
we like that. It's simple. No, there is
the element of obey God.
And it's a condition for receiving the
spirit. Of all the things God can do for
you or me, the greatest favor he can do
is to give us his spirit because the
person in whom the spirit dwells as a
guiding principle cannot be lost. Let me
say that again. The person in whom the
spirit dwells, now listen to my words,
as a guiding principle,
cannot be lost. That's why Romans 8:16
says, "The spirit itself beareth witness
with our spirit that we are the children
of God." It is the spirit as a guiding
influence that testifies to the Father,
"This is your child." Without that, a
person can be identified as a church
member, but not as a child of God. The
spirit's presence as a guiding principle
is the basis on which a person is
identified as a child of God. Ephesians
4:32, "Grieve not the spirit of God
whereby ye sealed unto the day of
redemption."
Amen. Amen. And just to piggyback a
little, can you say the verse that
after asking you have to, of course, be
obedient? Where is that verse you're
speaking from? Chapter 5 verse 32.
Perfect. 5:32.
All right.